hydrogen's my name's Matt you mentioned
earlier that you wrote mainly to explore
and discover new worlds and Westeros in
the world of song and ice and fire is so
rich so I'm wondering with what's left
in the books how much of Westeros do we
have left to discover and how much do
you write because it's necessary for the
story or do you write mainly because oh
hey this is a cool place to tell a story
you know the story takes over the story
makes its own demands there are other
parts of Westeros that you will see in
the last last few books I mean I haven't
I haven't board a action to de Casterly
Rock yet you've never seen Casterly Rock
you've never seen Highgarden I think
both of those locations will will play
key roles and in the books to come but
there is a lot of them and you know I
may do when I'm going years ahead now so
who the hell knows what will happen but
the world that I've created there is
rich enough to sustain many stories and
the Song of Ice and Fire is only one of
those stories so if I finish these last
two books that will be the end of the
story but not necessarily the end of the
world I think I would probably want to
do something else after I finish that
something very different and maybe some
short stories or maybe a science fiction
novel or or a horror novel I've been
thinking of some time but eventually if
assuming that of course I live long
enough and keep writing I might return
and tell all the stories set in Westeros
at different parts of Westeros different
historical epics or different continents
and geography so that might be fun
hey George big fan of yours and on your
right side so I just wanted to ask you
in terms of writing Renly a lot of
people were taken aback in terms of that
one scene that had shown up near the end
of the season and I guess they weren't
necessarily picking up on a lot of the
subtle hints that you had written in
the series so I was wondering if you had
wondered in terms of what fan reaction
would have been at the earlier stages of
the series towards reading a more
explicit scene like was seen between
Renly and the native flowers and how
that might have played out differently
if you had written it earlier in the
series in other words if I'd had a
explicit scene in the books is what
you're saying yeah well I don't know I
don't know what the reaction would have
been
you know I I do like to do certain
things
I don't know subtly I think subtlety is
is a virtue there there are things in
there that that some of my readers pick
up on and that other readers miss until
it's pointed out to them one of the
things of course that's changed in
recent decades with the advent of the
Internet is that the readers are sharing
their reading experiences so if if
there's something there and some readers
pick up on it and other readers don't
the readers who missed it soon become
aware of it by reading the blogs and
bulletin boards and and the people were
trotting out their theories and showing
all the hints and things like that so
that changes things but I like to I like
to reward the readers who are reading
closely and paying attention because
there there are a lot of thing I like to
write the books to reward rereading you
know I think the first time you read a
book you're reading for plot you read
what happens next
it's my hero is where the guy gonna live
or die or something like that and but
then if you go back and you reread the
book you may pick up things on a second
reading or even a third reading that you
missed the first time and you and you
see oh my god look what he's doing here
they look at his piece for shadowing or
look at this he said this and I didn't
notice it the first time but it's R it's
right there etc you know neither Renly
nor Loras is a viewpoint character and
since I'm
a very strict structure of seeing
everything through the eyes only of the
viewpoint characters there was really no
way to present explicit details of their
of their relationship without having
someone like walk in on them when when
which is sort of a I suppose I could
have done but it's a it's a clumsy
technique but a television show is is a
very different animal and doesn't
doesn't have to have the restrictions
the camera is your viewpoint there and
that viewpoint can be pointed anywhere
on any character it doesn't have to
necessarily just follow your six or
seven designated viewpoint characters
the major change of course is really
around perspective because the books do
change perspective and that the show
does not as much but it's it's all
through well I mean as a novelist you
have certain tools at your disposal to
tell a story with and these tools are
not available to a filmmaker I mean as a
novelist you are you know you have
internal monologue you can you can do
exposition simply as part of the the
narrative you know you have access to
the character's thoughts you can do
unreliable narrators where you you
really can't do any of this as a
filmmaker or a television director your
external you're never inside the
character I mean yeah you could try to
be there are those occasional
experimental films where you're looking
out through someone's eyes and there's a
voiceover telling you their thoughts
they're mostly terrible and don't work
very well you know the voiceover in film
is is a usually a technique that says
something really doesn't working here
and we're having to patch it over with
this clumsy voiceover technique and it's
frequently added at a later point like
the famous voiceovers in Blade Runner in
wood shop I think really detract from
the from that film and weren't necessary
but but you have other techniques that
make up for that as as a filmmaker or
television writer you have you have
tricks that are not available to
anomalous you can you can bring in music
to heighten suspense or to build up the
emotional impact of the of the scene you
you can do things with lighting and of
course you can your actors can bring a
tremendous amount to it with just a just
a look just the expression on their
faces I mean they the scene we showed
last night when I referred to in the
comments afterwards where King Robert is
arriving in Winterfell and he officer
off his horse and walks up to Ned and
you know looks at Ned and says you've
got fat and Shaun being just sort of
raises his eyes and looks I'm up and
down and the whole audience hell's with
laughter because of where this Robert
has really gotten fat that was something
that the two of them two of them did I
doubt it was even in the script I bet it
was I don't know some by play of the of
the actors but maybe it was in the
script but I certainly could not have
done that in prose I mean imagine trying
to write that in prose and how would it
go you know Ned you've got fat Robert
said Ned flicked his eyebrows they'd
raised his head up and dad doesn't have
the same impact that's actually seeing
Shaun beans face as he does that does
that little trick so you have to always
be aware of what medium you're working
in and and what things will work in it
and what things don't work in hi George
how difficult do you think it is for a
new science fiction or fantasy writer to
break into the industry it's actually if
you're good of course that's always the
purvey so you have to have half that
talent it's pretty easy to break in
actually you know I always advise new
writers young writers to to break in
with short stories that was the way I
did it in the in the 70s and that's
still the best way I mean we're
fortunate that science fiction/fantasy
still has half a dozen magazines
they're looking for new material every
month and therefore have to read their
slush pile in a fairly timely manner to
find the contents
you know the established writers there's
there's not much money in short fiction
you're not gonna get rich writing short
fiction by any means and the result is
that most established writers don't do
very much short fiction past a point
with certain point in their career they
switch to novels which is where you can
actually make a living so as a result
there's a lot of openings for new talent
in in the pages of analog and the
magazine of fantasy and science fiction
and Asimov's magazine and even nuit
magazines things like Lightspeed and
toward calm and and so forth
and my mind a good career path still as
it was in the 70s is to is to write a
whole bunch of short stories and sell as
many of them as you can and build a name
for yourself in the world of short
fiction because science fiction readers
and fantasy readers will will notice
these stories and then when you finally
do write your first novel and it hits
the stands it's not just gonna be the
the first novel by some new person that
you've never heard of in your life and
why should you pick up their novel when
you don't know who they are it's going
to be the long-awaited first novel by
this person who's published twenty short
stories and you know you've been seeing
their name in all the magazines and you
kind of like what they did so it gives
you a it gives you a leg up when you do
move to the to the world of novels and
that's a that's a good way to start